o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
se você já ouviu falar do Vale do Mucuri
em Minas Gerais Essa região é conhecida
como Circuito das Pedras Preciosas com
essa informação talvez você tem mais
lado lugar rica e abundante
é mas não é Infelizmente essa não é a
nossa realidade no Vale do Mucuri estão
algum dos Municípios com pior índice de
desenvolvimento humano do Estado Isso
quer dizer na prática que muitas pessoas
vêm com muita dificuldade como não ter
acesso ao saneamento básico em suas
casas principalmente aquelas pessoas que
moram na zona rural quando conhecer essa
realidade imediatamente me perguntei
qual a minha relação com este problema
é porque essa realidade me deixa tão
inconformado incomodado Talvez as
respostas para as questões estejam na
minha história e aos poucos você vai
entender que na verdade essa história
não é somente minha
hoje eu vou contar para vocês um
pouquinho da minha história bom durante
a minha infância lembro da época em que
minha mãe meus pais no final de semana e
eu Celebrar na zona rural de Resende no
estado de Rio de Janeiro ele e eu também
eu meus dois irmãos e minha irmã me
lembro dos lugarejos das casas simples
na estrada de chão e também das
dificuldades aquela população com a
falta de transporte educação e saúde e
principalmente me lembro das pessoas
acolhedoras que nos recebiam para
conversar e merendar nós vemos de Kombi
e levávamos aquela famosa marmita e na
volta que uma parte era muito boa da
viagem que a gente parava na beira da
estrada ia tomar banho um rio que
passava logo ali do lado
e hoje Relembrando vejo com importante
foi a sua época para o que eu sou hoje
para as minhas relações interpessoais
para minha vida profissional e para
minha paixão com o meio Rural
e a satisfação no rosto das pessoas
quando nós chegávamos são inesquecíveis
era o momento tão simples mas tão
importante para aquelas pessoas e para
os meus pais mas não entendíamos direito
que estava acontecendo naquela época mas
hoje quando tem a oportunidade de voltar
lá viu vejo quantas pessoas são graças
ao meu pai e minha mãe só vou levar uma
palavra de esperança e de vida
e já durante a adolescência tive
oportunidade de conhecer novas pessoas e
novos ambientes não é tão importante
onde pude ter contato com questões
políticas e culturais e também é claro
que tem momentos de atrito sem decisões
Afinal era adolescente né qual
adolescente não tem o momento de atrito
em Direito me decisões mas também nessa
época tive a oportunidade de tomar
decisões por o fundamentais para minha
vida é uma das decisões que tomei da
adolescência Claro com a ajuda de
pessoas muito especiais foi a de cursar
agronomia e aí lá fui eu para uma nova
aventura fazer agronomia na Universidade
Federal de Viçosa em Minas Gerais foram
Seis anos e meio de convivência com
pessoas dos mais diferentes locais
diferentes concepções e visões de Mundo
Foi um momento único de muito
aprendizado
e durante a faculdade tive oportunidade
de fazer um estágio que chamava estágio
interdisciplinar de vivência que os
possibilitou morar durante 13 dias com
uma família de agricultores familiares
na casa não tinha luz tomava banho de
balde com água sentado no fogão a lenha
o almoço era as nove horas da manhã ou
jantar 5 aprende a capinar bater feijão
foi uma experiência de vida formidável
devo muito da minha história esse
estágio as pessoas que participaram e
principalmente a família que me acolheu
mal sabiam eles que estavam contribuindo
muito para o meu futuro
e no dia da minha formatura tive mais um
presente além da formatura foi ficar
nuvens uma pessoa maravilhosa que hoje a
minha esposa dele ele que também é da
área da Agronomia casados vamos morar e
trabalhar numa cidade de chamar caiaque
aqui em Minas Gerais localidade de
quatro mil habitantes foi um período
muito rico de muitas conquistas
coletivas que nos enche de orgulho
ajudam a fortalecer o sindicato dos
trabalhadores rurais afundar escola
família agrícola Paulo Freire e uma
cooperativa de artesãos e agricultores
lá também conhecer e vivenciar mais de
perto essa questão da área temática da
ambiental
há algum tempo atrás para caso nós
encontramos com a presidente da
cooperativa de agricultores e artesãos
de Acaiaca e ela me falou
o Ricardo você e dele ele foram
fundamentais para o que nós somos hoje
uma fala assim gela de reconhecimento
mas que me tocou também profundamente
e também foi nessa época eu recebi dois
presentes de deus As queridas filhas
eliziara que são duas peças Sara figura
as pessoas muito especiais já em 2010 o
e dele no foram chamados por dois amigos
para trabalhar em Teófilo Otoni no Vale
do Mucuri a gente nem sabia direito onde
ficava Essa cidade e a gente precisava
tomar essa decisão em uma semana foi uma
decisão uma semana muito intensa para
gente e nós decidimos lá abraçar mais
essa missão sim a manutenção que a gente
veio fazer aqui em Teófilo Otoni no
início da conversa eu apresentei para
vocês lá em Mucuri vocês lembram região
onde grande parte da população não têm
acesso ao saneamento básico inclusive ao
banheiro dentro de casa
se você já imaginou como é viver sem
água encanada sem poder dar descarga e
sem ter a coleta de esgoto
bom e você já pensou que ter esses
acessos pode ter mudado o destino de sua
vida
e os impactos desse ter um banheiro que
o esgoto tratado São enormes da vida de
uma pessoa sabe por quê Pois porque não
ter significa ter que se deslocar para
fazer suas necessidades não tem
privacidade ser exposto a diversas
doenças perco contaminar o solo
contaminar a água enfim é não ter o
básico eram ter dignidade bom
trabalhando nessa região tive a
oportunidade de conhecer pessoas vivendo
essa triste e inquietante realidade e
foi algo que impactou o tanto que me
deixou inconformado e me levou a
contribuir na elaboração de um projeto
para levar o saneamento básico parece a
população Esse projeto é coordenado pelo
grupo de extensão e pesquisa Agricultura
Familiar o GP da Universidade Federal
dos Vales do Jequitinhonha e Mucuri e
possui uma equipe de professores
técnicos estudantes e voluntários uma
equipe de pessoas sensacionais que eu
tenho orgulho de fazer parte esse
projeto
a desenvolver saneamento básico Rural já
existe há seis anos e tem como objetivo
contribuir com a universalização no
saneamento básico na nossa região por
meio da difusão de sistema de coleta e
de tratamento de esgoto nas residências
das pessoas que vivem na zona rural e
também fomentar políticas públicas e
também promover a educação ambiental
e Já conseguimos impactar com essas com
as nossas ações centenas de pessoas e
também é construir em 24 sistema de
tratamento de esgoto doméstico e
parecendo agora de 2021 nós devemos
construir mais 28 sistemas e realizar
diversas outras ações e os anos
vindouros faremos muito mais e faremos
até que o nosso sonho de universalizar O
saneamento básico se torna realidade é
importante dizer que os resultados só
foram possíveis de serem alcançados pois
contamos com a participação de diversos
parceiros entre eles vão permitir
destacar as famílias beneficiadas que
também precisam contribuir com a
execução das ações e por falar em
famílias beneficiadas bolos contar
alguns relatos que inspiram para que o
projeto continue vivo e que faz a gente
fazem temos certeza que o que realizamos
faz sentido não só para nós mas para que
também para o próximo Afinal Precisamos
ser uma
e de todos estejam felizes e o básico
que já é o mini seja básico mesmo para
todos
o Ufa Vamos então você lados Vale contar
a história de uma dona de casa no
município de um bom de Formoso enquanto
enquanto construímos a fossa achamos que
ela tava meio de não tava dando muita
ideia para aquela força né que a gente
tá construído pela fazer é só ficar
dentro de casa e ao final da construção
da Foz foi lá vai dentro da casa chamar
ela para ver o sistema pronto que não e
aí o que que a senhora tá achando né que
que a senhora achou ela respondeu meu
filho Essa foi a coisa mais importante
que aconteceu na minha vida é claro que
os olhos marejaram pois Ficamos felizes
por poder contribuir com algo tão
simples mas tão importante para aquela
família e se ela foi muito importante
para o projeto Pois foi aprender a foto
que construímos Com certeza contribuindo
com a melhoria da qualidade de vida
dessa família agora foi um relato de
tamanha sinceridade humildade e não
permitiu que a soberba observar as
cabeças
um por um relato muito marcante
transformador para minha história de
vida
tá bom
e além desse Nós também Não vimos outros
relatos né como por exemplo para nós
essa daí foi a melhor coisa que
aconteceu no mundo no melhor que isso só
Deus no céu e mais graças a Deus
obrigado por ter um lado da cabeça de
todos que trouxeram essa obra
maravilhosa que está fazendo muita
diferença e vai fazer ainda mais
principalmente no tempo seco
Ah pois é muitas vezes um pequeno ato
como por exemplo uma solução tão simples
de tratamento de esgoto é capaz de mudar
a vida de várias famílias e
principalmente a minha história de vida
é porque porque nesse dia que a minha
história deve ser construído a partir de
ações
o que tem a capacidade de transformar
muitas vidas além da minha
é de ações que melhoram a realidade
daquelas pessoas que até então estão
excluídas de ter aquilo que é o básico
então a minha história me trouxe até
aqui e me fez conquistar muitas coisas
é mas ela não é só minha ela foi
construída pelo apoio Incondicional dos
meus pais irmãos irmãs esposa filhas
parentes vivência com os amigos e amigos
a Universidade de Viçosa pelos
conhecimentos que obtive morando com a
família de agricultor já Araponga Minas
Gerais pela minha participação na
história de agricultores familiares da
cidade de Acaiaca pelas vivências com os
amigos e amigas aqui no Vale do Mucuri
em especial para os agricultores
familiares e com todo o pessoal querido
do nosso getafe e por tantas outras
pessoas e situações a que não foram
possíveis relataram que neste momento
Oi e a polícia que eu afirmo a minha
história e as minhas conquistas não são
minhas Mas também de todas as situações
e pessoas que por ela passaram e pelo
relato dá para ver foram muitas e tem
certeza que ainda muitas virão para
construir essa bela história de
inconformismo e conquista inclusive você
que está aí nos assistindo e agora
queria fazer alguns desafios
E que tal você olhar para a realidade ao
seu redor e tentar mudá-la para melhor
E que tal você realizar ações que
melhorem a realidade das pessoas até
estão excluídas de ter aquilo que deve
ser o básico
E que tal você ajudar a transformar
muitas vidas além da sua e por fim que
tal transformar a minha EA sua história
na nossa história